each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
hello my name is Nathan wiebe today I'm
going to be talking to you about work
that I've done with Vadim Kolesnikov ah
that shows a whole new way of doing
quantum circuit synthesis and the key
points that I'd like you to be able to
take away from this talk are that we
provide a new non deterministic method
for synthesizing single qubit rotations
that's strongly analogous to floating
point arithmetic and our algorithm is
better than existing methods if the
rotation angle that we are trying to
synthesize is modestly small and a small
number of significant digits are
required and this is this is important
because of the fact that the cost of our
algorithm actually depends more strongly
on the number of significant digits
required rather than the size of the
rotation angle and this synthesis method
will obviously have applications in
quantum simulation and many for quantum
Fourier transform based algorithms so we
all know single qubit rotations are
important because any any arbitrary
single qubit unitary can be decomposed
into three axial rotations and so as a
result the cost of synthesizing an
arbitrary unitary depend i can be
reduced to finding the cost of
synthesizing individual axial rotations
and such rotations are of course also
used in other applications now you might
be thinking the single qubit axial
rotations are about the simplest thing
you can do experimentally so why do we
need to perform a synthesis and the
answer is in general of course we could
directly try to implement these things
experimentally but they won't
necessarily be robust against noise and
in order to do that we need to implement
them in a fault-tolerant fashion which
means that these continuous rotations
that are used have to be decomposed into
fault tolerant gates so there's many
sets of both taller and gates that can
be used commonly gates that are used
while tolerantly are the clifford gates
as well as non Clifford gates and for
many error correcting codes and in
particular the surface code Clifford
gates
are relatively simple whereas the non
Clifford gate is quite expensive so what
you want to do with a quantum circuit
synthesis algorithm is you'd like to be
able to make these rotations using as
few of these hard gates as possible so
there are a number of methods that have
been proposed to do this decomposition
the first and while most popular Matt
method is the soul of a kitaev algorithm
which has been used for years but this
year well within the last year new
methods have been proposed that actually
improve polynomially upon the
performance of the soul of a kiddie eval
group and in particular Selinger is
showing that an efficient decomposition
algorithm exists that gives a t count
that scales logarithmically with the
desired air and furthermore his method
is actually provably optimal for n
Scylla free single qubit synthesis in
that there will there are some unit area
rotations that need to be synthesized
that will have a coefficient of that's
precisely for for the minimum cost
required so that means that in general
if you're not using n sylla's you can't
you can't come up with an algorithm that
will be able to beat this coefficient of
for here however nonetheless we will
beat this for our particular cases and
what's the basic idea behind it what we
use to beat this well the assumption in
Sullinger's method is that no ansel
azure measurement are used we leverage
measurement and an Cilla's in order to
be able to do some really neat things
that you wouldn't be able to otherwise
do with traditional circuit synthesis
methods in particular what we do is we
give a way of effectively multiplying
the squares of rotations so imagine this
circumstance where you have access to
two rotations this rotation in this
rotation here so normally if you wanted
to add the two rotation angles you could
do that quite easily you would just do
the two rotations in series but if you
want to multiply them and that's
that's a little bit more difficult our
method uses and silicates in order to
achieve this feat and this fundamentally
is the building block behind our
floating point of decomposition so
what's the basic idea behind me circuits
how do they work well this is the
building block that we're going to
repeat over and over again in different
ways and in different scales in order to
be able to build our synthesis method
and the idea is as follows imagine
you've got a qubit that you'd like to
perform a rotation on and here isn't
just an N silly cubed that you initially
initialized to 0 then you begin by
performing this sum unitary on it a
controlled negative IX gate which is a
clifford operation on the qubit you want
to rotate and then you perform the
inverse of this operation and finally
measure the ANCYL a cuban there's two
outcomes if you end up getting zero then
you end up performing a rotation on the
ansel a qubit that roughly speaking ends
up giving an angle of theta that's
quadratically smaller than the value you
input up here whereas if you get one
then you apply a clifford operation
which can be easily inverted so the
basic idea about trying to implement a
rotation using these methods is as
follows you begin by trying the rotation
and measuring the measurement can either
succeed or fail if it fails well then
you actually haven't introduced any
errors that you can't correct so you
correct that using an appropriate
clifford operation and try the rotation
again repeating this as many times as
needed in order to perform the desired
rotation in practice however this this
actually doesn't require very many
repetitions in order to succeed and to
roughly two to three attempts are
usually sufficient for the such circuits
to succeed with high probability now
let's talk about a more complicated case
before I showed you how to effectively
square an input rotation angle now I'm
going to show you how you
can use the same idea in order to
multiply the squares of the vedas that
we used before so just like before what
you do is you have a single qubit that
you'd like to rotate and these are all
ancilla qubits initialized to zero what
you do is you then perform some unitary
you that you have access to on each of
these these qubits then you do a
multiple negative IX gate and this time
unfortunately this isn't a clifford
operation however the same protocol
curse you invert the corresponding
rotations after this and then measure in
the event that all of the measurements
turn out to be 0 then what you end up
doing is you end up performing a
rotation that roughly speaking is kind
of like the product of the squares of
all of their rotation angles that are
input and if it fails regardless of how
many ones are measured over here it
performs a clifford operation so we can
invert it now the key the key fit one of
the key insights behind the circuit is
that fundamentally what it does is it
takes large rotations that you know how
to do as inputs on each of these qubits
and then refines them into a much
smaller rotation over here and for this
reason we call this circuit a gearbox a
circuit because it transforms large
rotations into very fine rotations and
this is fundamentally the idea behind
our floating point synthesis method if
you wanted to perform this rotation here
then what you would do is you would you
would take you break this rotation down
into two components a mantissa component
and an exponent component and then
perform this multiplication circuit then
approximately after you after these
inputs you'll end up getting your
rotation that is close to the desired
one so at first glance this doesn't
appear like it has any advantage because
if you had to directly synthesize um and
ue then the cost could be four times as
large the cost of directly synthesizing
this rotation however there actually is
a substantial improvement frame many
cases because we can use our gearbox
circuits in order to come up with a much
more efficient way of generating the
small exponent unitary rotation and
furthermore if a small number of digits
of accuracy are needed the circuit for
um could be quite simple in particular
the way that we add in practice generate
the exponent unitary is actually by
doing repeated squaring so I mentioned
before that this circuit over here
essentially what it does is it takes a
rotation as input and then it outputs
the square of that rotation angle as a
rotation so this circuit over here you
can see actually is a repeated squaring
algorithm it takes takes theta and then
at this point it will output a rotation
that's angle theta squared at this point
it'll output of rotation is data to the
fourth and at this point it'll output a
rotation is they to the 8th so obviously
after a small number of repetitions of
this circuit it will end up generating a
truly small rotation angle also one of
the new features about this circuit is
that much of the cost actually can be
shifted off line or two parallel lines
of computation and you can see that in
that all of these boxes in here can be
actually shifted off line into n silly
preparations and furthermore many of
these operations here can actually be
done simultaneously resulting in a very
small T depth so now that we've I've
discussed the T depth and the offline
cost let me discuss what this actually
does to the t count which is the total
number of T gates that are needed to
synthesize the exponent part of the
rotation one of the things that you'll
see is that if we imagine trying to
synthesize ue using cell injures method
and we compare that to this curve over
here which is what we get by using the
tree like construction I showed you in
the last slide then you'll notice that
our construction is much more efficient
than cell injures method in fact we end
up requiring a number of T gates that
with ninety-five percent probability
will end up scaling like this in
Sullinger's method the corresponding
constant over here is four so we're
nearly a factor of four bed
then what Salinger's result would tell
you for this which is a substantial
improvement also on one of the things to
note though about this method is that
unfortunately though it's very efficient
it doesn't give you very good control
over the desired rotation angle so
you'll notice here what we have is we
have a situation where this is this
rotation is about 10 to the minus 25
radians the next one is to that's
permitted is 10 to the minus 50 that the
next one is 10 to the minus 100 and then
10 to the minus 200 so this is this is
hard to do for the circuit so what we do
is we actually combine our ideas and use
our multiplication circuit to multiply a
bunch of these exponent these tree-like
circuits in order to get much more
control over this and in effect enact a
binary expansion of the exponent doing
that you see that at a modest cost we
end up substantially improving the
spacing between the different exponent
unit Ares that can be obtained so this
is all well and good but it doesn't
actually talk about what the real costs
are for doing a actual rotation so here
we put all the costs together as an
example to show how expensive
synthesizing a this rotation which is
used in a quantum Fourier transform so
you'll see that over here these are the
best possible circuits that can be
synthesized using single qubit and cilla
free synthesis and the first circuit
that does a better job of proxy baiting
this rotation than the identity has 50
70 games whereas our floating-point
synthesis method gives a circuit with 21
T gates furthermore if we want something
that's comparable to that initial
approximation we require about 20 70
gates now what one other point to
illustrate is our method is fantastic if
the number of digits of precision is
relatively small as the number of digits
of precision increase we need a more
expensive mantissa unitary and as a
result it ends up costing much more
using quantum floating-point synthesis
in order to synthesize something with
small relative air so for this reason
our approach really should be thought of
as handling small rotations that you
need to perform all that accurately
whereas traditional methods are best to
be best to use for rotations where you
need a large amount of precision so in
conclusion we've provided a new method
for that for multiplying rotation angles
that can be used in order to enable a
floating-point synthesis of a rotation
angle and unlike traditional synthesis
methods the cost depends more strongly
on the relative precision and much of
the cost to the synthesis method can be
shifted to parallel computation paths
and this as future work may lead to so
improved methods for doing quantum
simulation where they're small but
barely non-negligible terms and also may
provide more efficient ways of doing
quantum Fourier transforms and other
related algorithms thank you very much